courage est
pour les chantiers s
elle est gentil
bon
je m'appelle evans ivan ma passion mais
si la cuisine est ce que je vais faire
aujourd'hui c'est que j'ai de la cause
de la papaye comme apophis yeux donc
comme j'ai déjà à moitié prix de billet
et là je veux retourner et continuer la
cuisson
on était une famille de deux des enfants
plus maman papa de gagner avec lui moi
quand papa est mort est bénigne m
vraiment un peu tout on était maman et
moi travailler quelques fois quand
j'arrive et je souhaitais travailler il
fallait la vie tout le linge de la
famille c'est une ambiance particulière
le matin comme ça dans la cuisine oui
parce qu'on est pratiquement sous le
bruit n'est pas encore arrivé le sirop
sa fille 20 centres damas comme ça qu'on
reconnaît bonjour bonjour vous avez bien
dormi très bien la vie revient bien
digéré oui aussi simple qu au plus bas
tant mieux comme vous prenez du temps
pour les achètent et lots est là et les
confitures tout est noté dessus tout est
fait maison ici comme tout le reste
si quelqu'un arrive je peux pas aider de
schumann
je me sens pas bien parce que j'ai pas
pu aider contenu
on les forces vives sont et veut laisser
des forces vives qui sont arrivés là
isomères chaque fois on a la manie
visible et la manif d'elle parce que
l'élève romain menuge aux ateliers
travaillent et y meurent
il faut toujours lire et à cuisine
toujours des fois le soir nous savoir
mehdi victime à molines a pouffé rien
regarder un peu télé et bien non il faut
toujours par exemple et mon âme n de
goya ouais et b6 est pas un il faut
toujours être question d'affaires avec
de quoi vous voulez le jus et 6 mai mais
qui démangent j'ai besoin de travailler
mes mains sur 776 bientôt 77 à ça
c'était le coin de mon marque donc à
ouidah fait side s'est déclaré hier je
sais ça et lespac je te retourne mais
avant mon beau père lui comme le
manguier vous voyez comme il y des
couches et donc il a effet il a fait un
maçon pour fuir ce fils y est là pour
protéger son mangue et pour pas couper
son mobilier société mob au pea
le papa de mon mari est lui aussi le
mauvais oui c'est ça
c'est une maison qui a toujours vécu
parce que c'est facile aux états
raconter même qu'on n'avait pas la clé
maubeuge mais tous les jours on a vécu
mon à manger tous les dimanches sur toi
il a dû faire ça pour qu'il y soit là on
le voit tout ce temps
c'était aussi un bain il ya une maman il
ya eu papa aussi et puis tous les deux
nous a donné le goût du travail entre
puisque même étant petit chacun baissé
de stabilité à la maison que ce soit
dans le ménage dans la cour au pape ce
soir au fil des années moment fait
et donc sa table d'hôte au départ qui
s'est transformé un an après ansermoz
verges et nous mêmes en tant qu'enfant
on a toujours travaillé dans l'ancienne
auberge pas soit au service
il y avait ma soeur mais france heures à
la cuisine au service et moi c'était la
cuisine
pourquoi j'aime cuisiner et baisse et
cédant sur moi et j'aime créer enfin il
y avait les restaurants mais il n'y
avait pas une table d'hôte et vous
connaissez le premier vaccin c'est et
maman c'était madame canaguy l est qui
on peut marier avec un canal il le sait
pas ce qui a fait barrage issa lô poulet
au moins vingt points comme ça en
janvier on va faire comme ça ben c'est
bien avant de rejoindre
oui ce sont bien les choses alors c'est
bon
chaque été c'est ce que ces prêts
c'est ça les enfants métier ah oui mais
avec toi on peut pas dire il ya une
recette fixe parce qu'aujourd'hui on dit
en mai sa demande où va mettre ça mais
je dis mes enfants si ça
pourriez vous me suivez c'est bien vous
connaissez la maison
l'avenir si on travaille on arrive
qu'ils continuent malgré demain matin je
serais plus là mais j'espère que ça va
continuer et qui ressemble à un l'on vit
déjà parce que même est pas prête du
tout avoir et partir parce que ça il
fermait parfois jamais manqué de rien
avec papa et maman
on a des mauvais moments on a des bons
moments mais tous comme ça il faut pas
prendre apple les mauvaises on ne garde
pas
merci